[Music]
joanne is in charlotte north carolina hi
joanne welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
so my question is i wanted to know if i
could
pause baby step four um
to get ahead on baby step six yes
joe are you trying to change the recipe
i no i'm not i'm not just hear me out
okay go ahead just hear me out all right
dave's got his judge hat on so go
oh no all right come on what are you
gonna say i'm
so i'm 34. all right and i can
pay off so right now if i continue to
follow the plan
i can bait off in 48 months however if i
pause it
i can do it in two and a half years and
i'm 34 i've already have about
110 000 in my 401 k and i
don't have any kids and so it sounds
what's your income
about 89 000. what do you do i'm an
accountant
and uh in in what function are you uh
working in a company as an accountant or
your cpa or no i work for a company as
an accountant
okay all right um so you're i
i far be it from me to correct an
accountant but your numbers are wrong i
do
um you did not include any you did not
include any raises
in your income 100 of which would go to
your baby step six
sure in this calculation and so it's not
an 18 you're talking about 18 months
spread here
two and a half to four right correct
yeah so it's probably more like a 12
month spread
and for 12 months i'm not stopping my
retirement
okay you can do it if you want but you
have to call it
joanne's plan you can't call it my plan
okay and i don't want to follow joann's
plan so it's okay you can
you can you can do it if you want you're
an accountant for god's sakes you make
90 000
a year you're not a stupid person so you
you just you know
but you just go this you know i don't
make i didn't do
uh dave's biscuit recipe i did mine
yup and you got muffins instead of the
biscuits
no really i mean the difference here is
12 months
no it's either way so it's not there's
nothing here either way she's going to
be okay oh yeah
you're right and here's the thing dave
she could take on a couple of side
clients
do some bookkeeping bring in an extra 10
to 12 maybe even 20 grand a year to
throw at the house
fix it and knock it all out but but
again
compound growth is necessary joanne you
know how to count
you know inflation is two to three
percent a year you know we can't go 12
months without throwing putting money
aside to help that compound growth
happen
in your 401k two and a half years yeah
two and a half
12 months nope on the payoff date yeah
so again joanne followed a plan
i like you and i'm i'm proud of you for
the progress that you've made
34 years old and you're talking about
owning your house free and clear
go rock it yeah by the time you're 35 or
40. this is pretty cool that's amazing